[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ملفات الخامسه من
العربيه والبدايه بابرز عناوين هذه
الملفات
البحريه
الى البحر الاسود
كرتون
عسكريه على الحدود مع الشمال السوري
[تصفيق]
الامن الايراني يواصل القمع بالداخل
ويلاحق لاعبي المنتخب في كاس العالم
والملف المستمر معنا في ازمه تويتر ماسك
يدعو لثوره ضد الرقابه على الانترنت
والبيت الابيض يدخل على الخط
اهلا بكم الى التفاصيل البدايه من اخر
التطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا فقد قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه بلانكن ان روسيا حولت
اجزاء من البحر الاسود الى منطقه حرب
مؤكده واشنطن لصواريخ قادمه من السفن
الحربيه الروسيه الى المدن والبلدات
الاوكرانيه كما اشار بلانكين الى تعزيز
وجود نيته في البحر الاسود الى بحر
البلطيقه
عندما يتعلق الامر بمنطقه البحر الاسود
فهذه منطقه ذات اهميه استراتيجيه حيويه
بالنسبه لنا ولحلف شمال الاطلسي حولت
روسيا اجزاء من البحر الاسود الى منطقه
حرب لقد راينا صواريخ خادمه من السفن
الحربيه الى المدن والبلدات الاوكرانيه
وسنقوم بتعزيز وجود الناتو من البحر
الاسود الى بحر البطيخ
[موسيقى]
بلينك النقاله ايضا انه واشنطن تواصل مع
شركائها حول العالم تقديم الدعم
الاوكرانيا مؤكدا ان واشنطن ستدعم
اقتصاديا وانسانيا في مجالات الطاقه وذلك
في مواجهه استهداف روسيا للبنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه
مش [__]
من شركائنا حول العالم لمزيد من التنسيق
والتصميم على دعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه
الاعتداءات الروسيه ونؤمن المساعدات لها
التي تؤدي الى تماسكها وسنقدم المزيد من
الدعم الاقتصادي والانساني وفي مجال
الطاقه
للبنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه التي تمد
مواطنين بالتدفئه والكهرباء
حوار سليم
هو في الايطالي نفسيه امين عام حلف الناتو
يانس السلطان برج اعتبر ان رئيس الروسي
بوتين يخفق في اوكرانيا ويحاول الاستفاده
من عامل البرد في فصل الشتاء واشار الى ان
روسيا تفشل في حربها على اوكرانيا مؤكدا
على ضروره ضمان ان تحافظ اوكرانيا على
سيادتها السلطان برج اضاف ان دول حلف
الناتو تدفع ثمن باهظا من جراء الحرب
الاوكرانيه محذرا من تداعيات هذه الحرب
التي ستدومي لسنوات طويله كما قال
كريت كنديشن يجب تهيئه الظروف لسلام دائم
يضمن ان تكون اوكرانيا دوله مستقله ذات
سيده يجب علينا الاستمرار في تقديم الدعم
العسكري لها لذا فان رسالتنا من بوخارستيه
انني تو سوف يستمر في الوقوف مع اوكرانيا
لاطول فتره ممكنه ولن نتراجع عن ذلك
خارجيه البريطانيه جيمس كليفر لان لندن
ستواصلوا دعم اوكرانيا خلال اشهر الشتاء
القادمه على حد وصفه بدورها قالت الحكومه
الايطاليه ان عليها القيام بدورها لمساعده
اوكرانيا في الشتاء في ظل ما تواجهه من
استهداف ان البنيه التحتيه من قبل روسيا
بالمقابل استبعدت روسيا عقد اجتماع بشان
اتفاقيه ستارت الجديده مع واشنطن قبل
نهايه العام واكدت ان على واشنطن المبادره
بشان المفاوضات النوويه المتبادله وان لا
خيار امامها سواء الغاء المحادثات بشان
اتفاقيه ستارت الجديده مع واشنطن وكما عزت
موسكو قراره ارجاء محادثات ستارز مع
واشنطن الى الوضع في اوكرانيا
ونذهب الى تطورات الحرب الميدانيه اعلن
انفصاله دوناس كاسيطره على ثلاث بلدات في
محيط مدينه بخموت شمال المقاطعه بعد معارك
مع قوه الاوكرانيه كما تحدثت مصادر
الروسيه عن قصف الاوكرانيين بصواريخ كليبر
استهدف وسط دارسك وفي لوغانكس اعلن
الانفصاليون احباطه هجوم وسائل القوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه سوفته وبالمقابل قال
مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان روسيا وصلت قصف
خرسون جنوب البلد وكان رئيس الاوكرانيه قد
اكد ان القوه الروسيه قصفت خرسون بنحو
158 مره خلال اسبوع وفي سياق ايضا طلب
مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني بانشائي محكمه
دوليه مختصه بالنظر في الجرائم المرتبطه
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه مشيرا الى ان
ذلك هو السبيل الوحيد لمعاقبه مسؤولينروس
هذا واطلقت اوكرانيا صفارات الانذار
لتحذير من غارات جويه روسيه جديده الا انه
لم يتم تنفيذ اي ضربات صاروخيه لتزيل كياب
اشاره الخطر رغم ذلك قال المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون انهم حضروا من شن هجمات
الروسيه جديده تحت غطاء طلاءات تدريبيه
وفي متابعه تطورات الميدانيه ايضا ذكر
الصحيفه تايم البريطانيه ان المدن الروسيه
وخاصه المناطق الحدوديه شهدت انتشارا
مكثفا للافتات ترشد الناس لملاجئ احتماء
من القنابل وذلك في وقت تدرس فيه الولايات
المتحده تزويده اوكرانيا باسلحه بعيده
المدى
وينضم الينا من موسكو مراسل عربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد مرحبا بك يا عبد الجواد نبدا
بالاوضاع الميدانيه وفكره وجود ملاجئ تقوم
روسيا باعدادها الان خاصه على المدن
الحدوديه هل هناك توقعات في الداخل الروسي
فعلا بان تمتد ان الضربات لتشمل العنق
الروسي او حتى المناطق الحدوديه في بعض
المدن
مرحبا بالرشا في البدايه اسمحي لي بان
اشير بان الخط الحدود الفاصل بين الاراضي
الروسيه والاكرانيه وقضيه التوتر الكبيره
الحاصل هناك وما يتبعه من غليان وتبادل
لاطلاق النار وتحليق للمروحيات والطائرات
الحربيه بالاضافه الى تبادل الصواريخ ان
كانت من الجانب الاوكراني او الروسي وعمل
انظمه الدفاع الجوي هناك هو اكبر بكبير من
قضيه ما يحدث اليوم رشا على شريط الحدود
هناك وتعرفون بان كاميرا العربيه صارت
وجالت هذا الخطا الحدودي بدا من الحدود
البولنديه وصولا الى البحر الاسود هو اكبر
بكبير الوضع هناك متوتر بشكل كبير بعض
المناطق الدخل من السكان بعد يعني قرار
السلطات باجلاء بالبعض منهم البعض منهم
وهم قريبون من الحدود من تلك المناطق طبعا
يتم انقطاع الكهرباء والمياه فيها وتسقط
فيها الصواريخ على نبيل المثال كانت حكومه
بلغراد يوم امس المداخمه للشريط الحدودي
مع الاراضي الاوكرانيه كانت قد اعلنت سقوط
العديد من الصواريخ على مناطق عده في تلك
المنطقه لذلك نلاحظ بان قضيه هي قضيه
واقعيه ويجب على السكان حسب ما يدور بين
يعني الحديث عن اللجان الشعبيه التي تقوم
بارشاد السكان بارشادهم باماكن تواجدها في
حال الحاجه لتلك المواضيع طبعا الصواريخ
التي تسقط من الجانب الاوكراني ومعظمها
ياتي من خارجف حسب الروايه الروسيه كانت
قد قالت مناطق عند ان كانت سكنيه وان كانت
صناعيه وبعض محطات توليد الطاقه لذلك طبعا
الخطوه الجديده والمرحله وهذه الموجه من
التهديدات بما يخص الضربات الجويه هي خطوه
متلاحقه لما كان يحدث خلال الفتره الاخيره
الماضيه خاصه بوجود طبعا عدد من القتلى
والجرحى ودمر بعض منازل والابنيه بالاضافه
الى المستشفيات ومحطه توليد الكهرباء وعمل
الانظمه الداخليه في تلك المدن المتاخمه
للاراضيه
يبدو اخطر بكثير من فكره الملاجئ فقط على
ما يبدو ان هناك شعور عام بان النطاق
الحرب ربما سيتسع ربما ستكون هناك ساحات
او نقاط جديده للمواجهه كيف لمس هذا الامر
هل كانت هناك تعزيزات عسكريه هل كانت هناك
همم ما يدور في الاوساط الروسيه حول مخاوف
من هذه النقطه او استعداد لها
رشا يعني عند التواجد في تلك المناطق
ونبدا من مدينه بيلغراد على سبيل المثال
نلاحظ بان اجواء المدينه والمدينه تحولت
الى سكنه عسكريه تواجد كبير لقوات الامن
تواجد كبير للمعدات على الشريط الحدود
الفاصل توتر كبير متصاعد تدقيق بشكل كبير
حتى على وسائل الاعلام اجلاء العديد من
السكان وبعضهم وصل الى هنا الى ضواحي
المدينه العاصمه الروسيه موسكو العديد من
يعني عددهم لا تقدر بالمئه ولكن اصبحت
تقدر بالالاف تم اجلاؤهم من الداخل الروسي
يعني المحايد لي الشريطه الاوكراني نحو
مناطق في الداخل اكثر امنا لذلك طبعا ما
لاحظناه من خلال رحلاتنا الى تلك المناطق
هو التوتر الكبير التكيف الامني بشكل واضح
والتدقيق في كافه الامور بدلا من الاوراق
الرسميه وصولا الى اصغر المعدات التي
يحملها
عبد الجواد الروس العربيه من موسكو شكرا
لك عبد الجواد على هذه المعلومات
هذا ونشره القوات البريه الاوكرانيه فيديو
يظهر نظام قاذفات صواريخ من طراز مارس 2
والذي قدمته المانيا وسبق لبيلين ان اعلنت
منتصف الشهر الجاري انها سلمت اوكرانيا
خمسه من انظمه مارتن اثنين اضافه لمدافع
الرئيسيه هي اصابه مجموعه من القوات
ومعدلات العدو بشكل الدقيق مثل المستودعات
ومخازن الوقود ومراكز القياده هذا هو
الفارق الرئيسي بين المعدات الصنع
والمعدات الغربيه
وانا انتقل الى الملف الثاني العمليه
العسكريه التركيه المرتقبه في شمال
السوريين في تطورات الميدانيه في شمال
السوري قال المتحدث باسم رئاسه تركيه
ابراهيم خليل ان العمليه العسكريه البريه
على سوريا قد تبدا باي وقت واكدت رئاسه
التركيه انقره فقط مع موسكو خلال العمليه
الجويه في شمال سوريا والعراق كم عاشر
المتحدث باسم رئاسه التركيه الى ان الحوار
بين انقره ودمشق على مستوى المخابرات
مستمر
وانضم الينا من اسطنبول لمراسله العربيه
زيدان زين كلو مرحبا بك زيدان ما يدور في
الاوساط التركيه السياسيه يشير الى عناوين
ربما ترتبط بمساله الاستعداد لشن عمليه
عسكريه بريه ولكن هذه التصريحات السياسيه
هل هي مقترنه بالفعل باجراءات معينه او
مؤشرات معينه لبدي هذه الحمله البريه
قريبا
في الشرق السياسي يحاول المسؤولون الاتراك
تسخين الاجواء يعني من خلال تصريحات توحي
بان العمليه العسكريه وشيكا في سوريا كما
قال اليوم ابراهيم كولن العمليه قد تبدا
اليوم ربما ربما الاسبوع القادم وفي الوقت
والمكان التي
تختارهما انقره همم هذه التصريحات ترى
فيها بعض المراقبين انها اولا تستهدف
الشارع التركي اي تهيئه الشارع التركي
لعمليه بريه في حال ارادت او فعلا كانت
انقر جاده في هذا الموضوع الشق الثاني
ايضا ان اقرا من خلال هذه التصريحات تريد
ايثار رسائل سياسيه الى موسكو واشنطن
اللتين
قوات في شرق وشمال سوريا بانها جاده فعلا
في عمل عسكري همم بري وشيك في عمق الاراضي
السوريه همم في المقابل همم موسكو واشنطن
لديهما مبادرات لنزع الازمه يعني السفير
الامريكي في انقره الاسبوع الماضي اقترح
على وزير الدفاع في اجتماع مشترك بمبادره
امريكيه تقضي بانسحاب المقاتلين الاكراد
بعمق 30 كم داخل الاراضي السوريه
وافتعادهم عن الحدود همم او ابتعادهم عن
الحدود التركيه في المقابل موسكو ايضا
لديها مبادره همم يوم امس كان قائد القوات
الروسيه في شرق الفرات والتقى بمظلوم
مظلوم عبدي قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وعلى ما يبدو ان هناك ايضا مبادل الروسيه
واقتراحات قالت مصادر سوريا انا من بين
هذه الاقتراحات انسحاب المقاتلين الاكراد
من المناطق الحدوديه القريبه من الحدود
التركيه طبعا حتى الان همم انقر لم تعلق
رسميا على هذه همم تسريبات هذه التصريحات
همم ما نشاهده الان هو تسخين ل همم
الاجواء والتصريحات سياسيه توحي بان العمل
العسكري وشيك في المقابله
هذه التصريحات المقترنه باجراءات عسكريه
بتعزيزات عسكريه باستعداد ما يبدو لهذه
العمليه ام انها مجرد تصعيد في اللغه
الاعلاميه فقط
ساكمل في هذا الموضوع في الداخل في
الميدان انقر منذ عام 2016 لديها قوات في
داخل سوريا في شمال سوريا وبعض المناطق في
شرق سوريا في ما تسميه منطقه نبع السلام
طبعا هذه القوات انقر عزيزتها بشكل كبير
خلال السنوات والاشهر الماضيه همم بات
هناك قواعد همم تركيا في جميع المناطق
التي تشهد وجود للمعارضه السوريه المدعومه
من انقره لذلك اليوم الحديث عن عمل عسكري
بالرؤيه التركيه والتصريحات التركيه يشمل
ترفعت ومنبج وعين العرب براي الكثيرين
يحتاج الى مزيد من التعزيزات اذا كان
العمل العسكري التركي محدود فقط في عين في
فقط في ترفعه والقرى العربيه المحيطه بها
ربما القوات الموجوده في الداخل تكفي لكن
عندما يتم الحديث عن عمليه تشمل ثلاث
محاور من ضمنها منبج همم المدينه الكبيره
في ريف حلب الشرقي وايضا عين العرب احد
اهم احدى اهم معاقل قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وحدات الحمايه الكليه الك يرى
ان اا هناك تعزيزات ربما ستكون حاضره في
الايام القادمه في حال ارادت فعلا انقره
البدء بعمليه عسكريه همم في حال فشلت طبع
المبادرات الروسيه همم الامريكيه ايضا
هناك جانب اخر لانه في هذا الموضوع الموقف
الامريكي والموقف الروسي نعم هناك تصريحات
امريكيه وتصريحات روسيه تؤكد على حق انقره
في الدفاع عن مصالحها لكن حتى الان لا
يوجد ضوء اخضر لانقر لبدء عمليه عسكريه
دائما العمليات العسكريه السابقه التي جرت
في 2016 و2018 و2019 كان هناك توافق ضمني
همم على نطاق العمليات التركيه التي جرت
في مناطق الشرق سوريا وايضا في مناطق شمال
شرق سوريا لذلك الان حتى الان هذه
التصريحات تتزامن بحسب كل المؤشرات مع
اتصالات سياسيه ومبادرات سياسيه سواء ما
بين اتصالات ما بين همم انقره واشنطن
وانقره وموسكه وايضا من قبل موسكو واشنطن
لنزع فتيل الازمه في حال حققت يعني هذا
همم ما ترجحه الاوساط
السياسيه التركيه في حال حققت هذه
المبادرات ما تريده
الاتصالات
العربيه من اسطنبول شكرا لك
بالمقابل قال قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
مصدومه عبدي انه لا يزال يخشى هجوما بريا
تركيا على الرغم من التاكيدات الامريكيه
وطلب برساله اقوى من واشنطن للضغط على
تركيا المسؤول الكرديه قال انه لا يعول
على الدفاعات الجويه السوريه الضعيفه
نسبيا بعد ان عبر في وقت سابقا عن امله في
ان تساعد في الدفاع عن قوته من ضربته عن
الجويه
وينضم الينا من برلين الكاتب والباحث
السياسي الكرديه رستم محمود اهلا بك سيد
رستم هناك حاله من التذبذب في تكوين
الموقف الحالي فيما يتعلق بعمليه عسكريه
بريه واسعه لتركيا في شمال سوريا البعض
يقول ان امريكا لم تقم بالدور الذي يمنع
من هذا الامر وانا تنسيقا تركيا روسيا عن
الجانب الاخر يتم بالفعل كيف يمكن ان نقرا
هذا المشهد الملتبس
يعني المشهد الملتقى اسمه تاتي من عدم
قدره تركيا من اطفائيه شرعيه على العمليات
العسكريه التي قامت بها من قبل عمليات
القصف على المناطق الكرديه وكمال شرق
سوريا تصريحات الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تقول انها لا تعرف من قام بعمليه
تقسيمت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انه لا
علاقه مطلقه
لحزب العمال الكردستاني ولقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في تلك العمليه هناك ارتباك
داخل المشهد السياسي وداخل المشهد الامن
التركي يعني اللجنه البرلمانيه التي شكلها
البرلمان التركي حتى الان لم تستطع لم تصل
الى ايه وثائق على الاجهزه الامنيه وزاره
الداخليه التركي
هناك كلام كبير في الصحافه التركيه انه
منسقه العمليه على اتصال بالحركه القوميه
شريكه حزب العداله والتنميه في الحكومه
انه هناك يعني علاقات عائليه للشخص الذي
قامت بهذه العمليه بالجيش الوطني السوري
المرعي من قبل تركيا هذا الارتباك السياسي
داخل تركيا في وضع سياسي لا تستطيع في
حكومه اردوغان الا ان تقوم بعمليات
استفزازيه عسكريه لتشد العصب القومي
التركي اللي هي لان هناك مشكله كبيره جدا
في النواحي الاقتصاديه والنواحي التنمويه
جميع المؤشرات تشير قبل سته اشهر من اجراء
الانتهابات نهايه العمر السياسيه
وموقف واشنطن هل الجانب الكردي يشعر بان
واشنطن حليف حقيقي له هذه المره لان تم
التحليلات تشير الى ان ما تقدمه واشنطن من
دعم هذه المره او على الاقل منع تركيا من
هذه العمليات يبدو مختلفا عن ادائها في
السابق هل هذا الانطباع موجود فعلا
سيد رستم هل تسمعني يبدو ان لدينا مشكله
فنيه سنحاول العوده له مره اخرى الكاتب
والباحث السياسي الكرديه رستم محمود من
برلين سنحاول العوده له
تعدوا بكين وكما سنشاهد من خلال هذه الصور
لاطلاق المركبه الفضائيه الماهوله شنتشو
وسينافذ المهمه رواد ثلاثه من الفضاء
الصينيين وسيتم اطلاق المركبه من مركز
زيوت لاطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه بشمال غرب
الصين حيث سيبقى رواد في مهمه لمده سته
اشهر
هذه الصور للمركبه الفضائيه الصينيه التي
سيتم اطلاقها بعد برنامج بدا طموحا للغايه
للصين في مجال الفضاء نجحت من خلاله في
اطلاق بعض المركبات احيانا واخفقت في
الجانب الاخر ولكن يبدو ان هناك صحوه
فضائيه صينيه خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه
هذه هي صور ايضا لرواد الفضاء الثلاثه
الذين سيحبون هذه المركبه الى الفضاء
ونبقى معكم في نشره الخامسه من العربيه
ولدينا
المواجهه بين ايران والولايات المتحده
تتحول من السياسه الى كره القدم
في تطورات الاحتجاجات في ايران افادت
تسجيل صوتي المسرب عقب اختراق وكاله انباء
فارس شبه الرسميه بان عددا من مسؤول
الاعلام الرسمي اعربوا عن قلقهم من ارهاق
قوات الامن على خلفيه قمع الاحتجاجات
واضراب التجار في اثنتين 22 محافظه
ايرانيه وفي اعتراف ايرانيا متاخر قال
امير علي زاد قائد القوات الجويه في الحرس
الثوري للمره الاولى ان اكثر من 300 شخص
قتلوا في التظاهرات حتى الان لكن بنسبه ما
فان منظمه نشطاء حقوق الانسان في ايران
قالت ان هذه الحصيله الرسميه تقل بكثير عن
الواقع وتقول هذه المنظمه ان اربعه واحده
و50 محتجا و60 من قوات الامن قتلوا بالفعل
منذ بدا هذه الاضطرابات كما اعتقل اكثر من
18,000 شخص
هذا هو اعلنت شرطه طهران عن اعتقاله خمسه
اشخاص وصفتهم بعناصر مثيره للشغب في حي
نادي اباد شرق العاصمه
الى ذلك قال مصدر معني بامن المباريات في
كاس العالم بقطر لشبكه سنان الاخباريه
الامريكيه ان عناصر تابعه للحرس الثوري
يراقبون لاعبي منتخبهم ويعملون على جمع
معلومات عنهم واشار المصدر لشبكه سنان
الاخباريه الى ان اللقاءا جمع مدرب
المنتخب الايراني مع ضباطن من الحرس
الثوري دون ذكر تفاصيل مضيفا ان عائلات
لاعبي منتخب ايران تعرضت للتهديد بالسجن
والتعذيب اذا لم يحسن اللاعبون التصرف كما
اكد المصدر استدعاء اللاعبين للقاء اعضاء
في الحرس الثوري عقب رفضهم غناء اناشيد
الوطني في المباراه الافتتاحيه امام
انجلترا
واعمل تورنتو الصحفيه في تلفزيون ايران
انترناشونال ماس مارتدون واهلا بيكي
السيده محسن معنا يبدو ان هناك اجراءات
انتقاميه جديده ستكون من قوات الامن او من
النظام الايراني ضد لاعبي المنتخب
الايراني كيف يمكن التعامل مع هذا الارهاب
او ما يسمى او ما يبدو من انه ارهاب لهذا
المنتخب باعتبار انه اتخذ موقف يبدو
مساندا الاحتجاجات في ايران
اوك لمين
حدث قبل ربع قرن عندما كانت قد كسبت ايران
مباراه في مواجهه ان النمسا في تلك الفتره
كان الشعب الايراني
في ذكر الشعوب الايرانيه بالنسبه لكره
القدم لكن اليوم بنفس التاريخ الامر قد
اختلف كليا عن مكان عليه الحال في السابق
هذه الايام ايران تعاني من انتفاضه كبيره
للشعب الايراني منذ اكثر من شهرين
والقوات قد انهكت من قمع الناس وتسعى
للحصول على قلوبه وعقول الناس مره اخرى
تسعى لاجبار الناس اللي توقف عن المظاهرات
لكنها لم تفله لذا فانها تحاول ان تقوم
بالحصول على امتيازات الفريق الوطني
لتقوله بانها تقف الى جانب الشعب لكن هذه
الكذبه لن تنطلي على الشعب الايراني لانهم
يشعرون
بقلق بعد مقتل ما يصل الى 500 شخصيه يعني
50 منهم من الاطفال هو همم لعل الناس
يشعرون بالسعاده اذا ما حققه الفريق
الايراني ولا سيما بوجود المعجبين الكسر
لكنهم لابد لهم ان يعبر عن مشاعرهم هذا ما
كان قد اظهره في المباراه الاخيره حيث
استطاعت ايران ان تكسب مباراه
كبيره ولو اظهروا لكم بعض اللقطات الفيديو
للناس الذين كانوا يرقصون ويحتفون في
شوارع في الوقت ذا كانت الشرطه تقوم
باعتقال الناس
ولكن وتنتهي هذه الفرصه ليس فقط من اجل
جعل الشرطه وقوات الامن همم سعيده بل انها
تسد تقوم بانتهاذها باذامات اذا ما كانت
المباراه المقبله في مواجهه الولايات
المتحده
بدات
نتائج جيده وهناك بعض الوثائق التي تم
تسريبها من من وكاله اخباريه
محطه التلفزيونيه ايرانيه ان هذا جزء من
المشروع لجعل الفريق الوطني
مملوكا من قبل الحكومه والاستخدام السمعه
التي تخص حكومه
وهذه المستندات اظهرت بان الفريق الوطني
بمبالغ ماليه كبيره وقد تعرض للتهديد
بانهم لان لم يقوموا بترديد النشيد الوطني
فانهم سوف يتم همم
بعيدا عن المنتخب الوطني سوف تكون لهم
تابعات كبيره
وقلنا قد راينا الفريق قد ادى بالنسبه
للنشيد الوطني
مختلفتين في المباريات السابقه
ولعلنا اخذنا هذه الاجراءات لن تفرح التي
سوف يستخدمها النظام في الحصول على
امتيازتهم مجددا
شكرا لك السيده محسن مرتضى الصحفيه في
ايران انترناشونال على مشاركتك لنا على
شاشه العربيه
عبرت اسره البلجيكيه اوليفيا ستيل العامل
في المجال الانساني والموقوف دون سبب في
ايران منذ 9 اشهر عن خلقها من تراجع حالته
الصحيه مشيره الى انه بدا اضرابا عن
الطعام للاحتجاج على معاملته بطريقه غير
انسانيه على حد وصفها ونددت عائلته بما
وصفته بالظلم الوحشي ناقله فحوى تصال يقال
ان المواطن البلجيكي اجره مع قنصليه بلاده
وبلشان المباراه المرتقبه بين منتخبي
ايران والولايات المتحده اليوم اعرب وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطون بلانكن عن ثقته
في فوز المنتخب الامريكي امام نظيره
الايراني في اطار مباريات كاس العالم كما
اكد لينكن عدم وجود اي جوانب جيو سياسيه
او خاصه في هذا الشهر
مرسيدس
مباراه رياضيه ولكن بطعم سياسيه ننتقل
الان الى موجز كاس العالم مع زميلته لليان
تنوري
[موسيقى]
صلاح
طيب الذكر
بسرعه في الالتحام غير يعني غير شوف قصير
بس انه يطلع معاك في الارتقاء يطلعوا ما
شاء الله يعني
احسن طريقه معاهم
تلعب بحظر بصراحه
الفرنسيه الفرنسيه
غادر حارس مرمى انتر ميلان اندريا اونانا
تشكيله الكاميرون في قطر بسبب خلافات مع
المدرب رجوبل سونج وبحسب صحيفه الاجازات
الدوري الاسباني
توجه الى المطار ومن هناك سيتجه عبر باريس
الى بيوند عاصمه الكاميرون وكان حارس مرمى
اياكس السابق قد استبعد من المباراه امام
سوريا لاسباب تاديبيه وافادت التقارير ان
المدير الفني للمنتخب كان لديه شكاوى بشان
حارس المرمى بسبب تحمله الكثير من المخاطر
في اسلوب
يعود المنتخب السعودي الى استاد لوسيل
الذي شهد انتصاره التاريخي امام الارجنتين
وهذه المره لخوض المواجهه الحاسمه امام
المنتخب المكسيكي الاخضر سيصل الى هذا
اللقاء غدا وهو يواجه معدله الغيابات فرما
تعافي رياض شراحيلي من الاصابه الا ان
رينار سيفتقد خدمات محمد البريك لسبب
لنفسه وعبد الاله الملكي بسبب الايقاف
فيما تحوم الشكوك حول مشاركه لاعب الوسط
محمد كانو بعد غيابه عن التدريبات
الجماعيه
وعلى استاد المدينه التعليميه يتشابه
منتخب تونس في امريكا الى دور المقبل
عندما يواجه حامل اللقب المنتخب الفرنسي
يملك نسور قرطاج نقطه واحده في رصيدهم بعد
التعادل امام الدنمارك في جوله الاولى قبل
الخساره من استراليا في مضامين المنتخب
الفرنسي تاهله الى الدوري المقبل بعد فوزه
في الجولتين الاولى والثانيه
وما يعرفوه اللي تم حتى شيء مستحيل في كره
القدم
كل الثقه وكل التحفيظ مش الحق والنتيجه
ايجابيه ان شاء الله نكونوا موافقين اهم
شيء المعركه الاخيره بحول الله بشرف
وضع كريم بنزيما ونجم ريال مدريد حدن
الشائعات بشان امكانيه عودته لصفوف في
منتخب فرنسا لاستكمال منافسات كاس العالم
ونقلت شبكات راديو مونت كارلو مقطع فيديو
لوصول بنزيما الى جزيره رينو الفرنسيه
صباح اليوم ليقضي اجازه لمده اسبوع اضافت
انا بنزمه قام باستئجار منزل في الجزيره
التي تقع في المحيط الهندي وسيبقى هناك
رفقه بعض اقاربه واكدت الشبكه الفرنسيه
انا بالذمه لا يزال مدرجا في قائمه
المنتخب الفرنسي ويمكن للمدرب ان يستدعيهم
مجددا لكن الفرصه فضائيه في ظل طبق اقل من
ثلاثه اسابيع على المباراه النهائيه لكاس
العالم
توم وجيري
تحدثت مع بنزيما بعد مغادرته ووضعه سيء
ويحتاج الوقت من اجل الشفاء مواجهه تونس
لن تكون سهله سيلعبون بكل قوه من اجل
تحقيق الفوز والتاهل لكننا سنخوض المباراه
بجوده كبيره رغم ضمان التاهل الى دور ال16
الايراني
بعد غيابه عن مونديال روسيا 2018 فيما قد
يكون التعادل كافيا لمنتخب ايران في حال
خدمتها نتيجه انجلترا معاويه للوصول الى
الدور الثاني للمره الاولى في تاريخها
انا لا اعلم كيف سيلعب المنتخب الايراني
هل سيدافع او يهاجم انا لست مدربهم لكن
نحن علينا الهجوم قدموا مباراه جيده امام
ويلز وبالتاكيد سيعملون على المضيق قدما
بنفس المستوى والاداء الاهم ان نركز على
اداءنا ونفوز
في المجموعه الانجليزيه مع منتخب ويلز
تجاره الاخيره كما ذكرنا الفريق
الانجليزيه لديه اربع نقاط من مبارتين
فيما يحتلوا الفريق اللويزي المركز الاخير
في المجموعه واحده يجب على ويلز الفوز على
انجلترا للمره الاولى من طعام 84 وان
يتعادل المنتخب الايراني معا نظيره
الامريكيه في مباراه الجوله الاخيره من
المجموعه من اجل ضمانه تاهله
اعتدنا على اللاعبي تحت الضغط وتصنيفنا
ضمن قائمه المرشحين للفوز باللقب فوزنا
على ويلز مهم جدا للتاهل في الصداره نعلمو
حساسيه المواجهه ودافع ويلز للفوز علينا
يجب ان يكون حذرين مع جاريث بيل نظرا لما
يمتلكه من مهارات
ه والبقاء معا نحن سعداء بالتواجدين هنا
ولكن سنبذل قصار جهدنا للتاهل لا اشعر
بمسؤوليه اضافيه
والامر لا يتعلق بلاعب واحد
اصبح المنتخب البرازيلي ثاني متاهلين الى
دور ال16 بعد ان تجاوز امس نظيره السويسري
بهدف من دون رد ضمن مباريات المجموعه
السابعه هدف البرازيل الوحيد سجله
كاسيميرو يضعف رصيده ست نقاط من انتصارهن
تصدر بهما مجموعه بينما تجمد رصيد سويسرا
عند ثلاث نقاط كان قد جمعاها من فوز على
الكاميرون في المجموعه في مواجهه الاولى
شهاده المباراه
مساعد والذي الغى هدفا برازيليا كان قد
سجله نجمه فينيسس
[تصفيق]
معرفه
بناءها على مدى اربع سنوات والفوز هذا
المساء جزء من هذه العمليه بالاضافه الى
العمل خروج بكيتك كان اخيرا تكتيكيا لاننا
ادركنا كيف نقرا المباراه
سويسرا كانت افضل دفاع في التصفيات ولديهم
اسلوب مختلف عن منتخب صربيا سويسرا تملك
لاعبين مميزين لكننا عرفنا كيف نسير
المباراه
الثانيه الهدف الاول في الدقيقه الرابعه
والخمسين وبدا كان رونالدو من لمس الكره
لكن الهدف عاده
الثاني من ركله الجزاء البرتغال رفعت رصيد
الى 60 نقاط
عند نقطه واحده
اعتقد ان فريقي يستحق الفوز والتاهل الى
الدوري المقبل كنا اقوى واخطر على المرمى
بعد الاستحواذ على الكره بشكل افضل هذا
الفوز لا يحمل اي مشاعر انتقاميه بعد
اقصائنا في المونديال الماضي امام
اوروغواي انا لا اشعر الان سوى الفوز
والتاهل حققنا وكنا نسعى اليه في بدايه
المشوار وهو حصد 60 نقاط الان يجب الحذر
من ما هو قادر
لكن اللاعبين لم يستغل الارض
الجوله الاخيره يجب علينا ان نلعب بشكل
اسرع من اجل هز الشباك وصناعه الفرس
المباراه
في افريقيا
انا الرابعه
يعني عنده خبره كبيره وعمل مع المنتخبات
وايضا وصلهم الى كاس العالم واخرها 2018
المغرب همم
الطريقه الايجاز يدير فيها المنتخب انا
اشوف ان عقلانيه ومنطقيه
اللاعبين اللي يلعبوا معها في التصفيات
الى الان متمسك فيهم وهمم لغه الحوار معهم
همم
يعني احس انها مرتاحه لها هو كان مدرب
[موسيقى]
شكرا لجميلاتي ليليان صراع جديد بين لهم
ماسك والمعلمين على تويتر
من على متاجر التطبيقات للهواتف الذكيه
سبب ذلك التغيرات في المحتوى التي يفرضها
الملك الجديد تويتر
مناوشات تغريده وتصريحات يبداها ايلين
ماسك بين الفينه والاخرى منذ ان اصبح
الطائر الازرق من ممتلكاته
تغييرات جذريه اجرها ماسك في سياسه الشركه
تبدو ذات ايقاع سريع لم يناسب الموظفين
والمستخدمين تداعيتها تبدو اوضح يوما بعد
يوم اخرها الحرب المصغره التي جرت بين
ماسك وشركه ابل التي اوقفت اعلاناتها على
تويتر خوفا من الخطط الجديده التي يعدها
ماسك بخصوص المحتوى وتحديدا من تحولها الى
منصه للمعلومات المغلوطه وخطاب الكراهيه
الملياردير الامريكي اتهم عملاقه
تكنولوجيا بالوقوف ضد حريه التعبير مغردا
عبر منصته
ومتخوفا من فقدانها في البلاد تغيرات في
المضمون يراه ماسك في مصلحه حريه التعبير
بينما تنظر اليها شركات الاعلان طريقه
لنشر المعلومات المظله وخطاب الكراهيه من
قبل بعض المستخدمين ما ادى الى النزوح
جماعيا للاعلانات عن المنصه ليدخل البيت
الابيض على خط الاسماء مؤكدا على ضروره
مراقبه من الصون ونشاطها الجديد
من المعلومات الخاطئه والكراهيه التي
نراها ويجب عليها اتخاذ الاجراءات ونحن
نراقب وضع تويتر الان عن كسب
انسحابتهم بجمله يقوم بها المعلنون كما
المستخدمون قد تؤدي الى خسائر ماليه هائله
في تويتر الا ان ازمه المحتوى التي مقها
ماسك قد لا تقتصر على الخسائر الماديه بل
تتجاوز ذلك الى التهديدات بايقاف التطبيق
على متاجر الهواتف الذكيه والتي هددت بها
ابل لكن الحل السحري السهل كان لدى ماسك
وهو انتاج هواتف جديده اذا عمر العربيه
السيد ايهاب عباس مرحبا بك سيد ايهاب من
جديد تويتر في مرمى السياسه هل بالفعل
هناك مؤامرات كما يروج بعض المقربين من
ماسك عليه من قبل شركات الاعلان لمحاوله
تحطيمه وكثر مشروعه في تويتر
اهلا بحضرتك استاذه رشا واهلا بكل
المشاهدين من الممكن ان نقول ذلك
والامور في الواقع ستنتهي الى كل فريق من
يؤيد هناك فريق اؤيد الى الماسك واتجاهاته
الجديده في تويرر وهناك فريق يؤيد طبعا
الديمقراطيين والشركات التابعه
للديمقراطيين ويرون ان ما يقوم به البيت
الابيض اليوم اعلانه بانه سيراقب تويرر
والمحتوى الداخلي همم لهذه المنصه الكبيره
يروا انه هو نوع من انواع التواغل على
الحريه يعني هناك دائما رايه اخر في هذا
الايطار لكن بكل تاكيد ما يخلقه اليوم الى
الماسك من حاله جذب واستقطاب بين الفرق
السياسيه وحتى الفرق
التكنولوجيين انجاز التعبير بينه وبين ابل
وبين جوجل كلها امور في الواقع لا تصب في
مصلحه الدخل الامريكي وانما تصب في مصلحه
استقطاب اكبر على مستوى الحزبين اديم
والجمهور اصبحت منصه ويرل اليوم ينظر
اليها على انها جمهوريه الهوى بل جمهوريه
وربما جمهوريه يمنيه الهواء وهناك من يارا
طبعا في بقيه الشركات والمنصات الاخرى
كايوتيوب وجوجل طبعا تتبع لها يوتيوب
والمؤسسات الاخرى التابعه لابل وغيرها
وانستجرام وتيجي تاغ وكل هذه المواساه ال-
ال- البلاد فورمز الاخرى او المنصات
الاخرى في الواقع على انها نوعا ما تميل
ناحيه الديمقراطيين
فيما يتعلق بالازمه الحاليه مساله خطاب
الكراهيه او التعدي على حريه التعبير او
استخدام بعض الادعاءات بفكره المعلومات
المعوطه من الطرف الذي يحق له ان يحدد اذا
كان هذه او هذه تغريده تعد وخطب كراهيه ام
لا تنشر معلومات مغلوطه ام لا لان انا
نعود بهذه الازمه من جديد الى ازمه ترامب
هذه مشكله موجوده في المجتمع الامريكي
خاصه ان الرقابه على المحتوى الالكتروني
لا يوجد بها قوانين وتشريعات صادره من
الكونجرس الامريكي وربما هذا يكون امر
يناقشه الكونجرس خلال الفتره القادمه لان
الامور اصبحت متزايده هناك منصات اصبح لها
تاثير قوي جدا على المستوى السياسي وعلى
المستوى الاقتصادي واثاره حتى ااه يعني
قضايا هامه في المجتمع الامريكي واثاره
خلافات ومشكلات واصبحت من السطل تجميع من
الممكن انجازات التعبير الى القوم القول
اشخاص بشكل معين ليقوم باعمال معاينه كما
حدث في السادس من يناير عام 2021 والخطاب
باستخطابي للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
اصبحت هذه المنصات تحتاج تحتاج الى رقابه
شديده غير متوفره الان في القانون
الامريكي ولا الدستور الامريكي لذلك اساس
الامريكيون خلال الفتره القادمه اعتقد
سيفردون الكثير من الرقابه ونذكر هنا
عندما سئل مارك ذكر
شركه ميتا فيرس حاليا طبعا وهي فيسبوك
عندما سئل في الكونجرس في استجوابه كشاهد
همم عندما سئل هل هل هل من الممكن ان نعرف
اين انت كنت اليوم قبل ساعه فقال لا فا
قالوا له النواب اذا لماذا تعرف عنك كل
لحظه وكل دقيقه ماذا نحن نتحدث واين نحن
موجودون
لسبب الدعايه الاعلانيه وطبعا تستخدم بعد
ذلك في جمع المعلومات لتوفيرها للسياسين
حتى لتوجيه خطابات معين اذا نحن امام فصول
ستتجدد خلال الايام القادمه في ازمه تويتر
الكاتب السياسيه من واشنط ايهاب عباس
تحياتي
ونبقى معكم في سياق نشره الخامسه من
العربيه ولدينا
باكستان
مع طالبان حول تهديدات الامنيه ومدارس
الفتيات
اهلا بكم من جديد قال مستشار الامن القومي
الاسرائيليه الهلفافه ان ايران لم تعد
مشكلته لاسرائيل فقط ما المشكله عالميه
نقل جندل مان المتحدث باسم رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيليه قوله ان التحدي الامنيه
الرئيسيه الذي يواجه اسرائيل لا يزال
يتمثل في ايران وهو تهديد له ابعاد متعدده
واضافه لك ان الملف ناويه الايرانيه
ونشاطه اهرام في المنطقه هما نواه هذا
التحدي الامني مشيرا الى ان ذلك يمتد الى
ما وراء حدود اسرائيل
وصلت وزيره الدوله لشؤون الخارجيه
الباكستانيه حنا رباني الى كابول والتقت
مسؤولي طالبان لبحث ملفات عده على راسها
التهديدات الامنيه والحركات الارهابيه
التي تتحرك من الاراضي الافغانيه اضافه
الى ملفي عمل المراه ومدارس الفتيات اهميه
زياره تاتي بعد الغاء طالبان الباكستانيه
هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار مع القوه
الباكستانيه يذكر ان الهدنه جاءت بعد
وساطه حكومه الطالبان افغانستان بين
الطرفين في اغسطس الماضيه
[موسيقى]
توصلوا فرق الانقاذ في ايطاليا عمليات
البحث عن مقاطع
في جزيره اشيا بخديجه نابولي جنوب البلاد
فيما اظهرت صور جويه التقطها حفر السواحل
الايطالي حجم الدمار الذي لحق بالمنازل
والسكان
[موسيقى]
هذا هو شاهد الجزيره هاواي الامريكيه
ثوران هو الاول من دون نحوي 40 عاما
لمونالو اكبر بركان نشط في العالم
[موسيقى]
انتهت ملفات الخميس يا عم من العربيه
خدمهنا الاخباريه مستمره على مدار الساعه
ابقوا معنا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]